so we haven't looked at search for a
little while and they get messy because
the numbers don't like to talk to each
other until of course you can start to
simplify some of those thirds so let's
have a look at Aaron's first line what's
he done here what's this first line
about what's he trying to do he's um
he's got brackets here and he has no
brackets here so what is the process
he's gone through he's expanded very
good and he's done that in two stages he
said okay look what this means is I want
to have square root of eight lots of
this and I want to have three lots of
this I do both of them so that's what
this line is about I think it's wise to
do that in two stages because if you do
it all in your head if you're confident
and quick great but if something goes
wrong in this line and you don't have
the previous one it's much harder to
work out what what has gone wrong so we
can see here five route eight does that
look good
blada rhetorical question five or eight
it does look good right okay good to
route 16 that's come from these two is
that yeah there's that what happens to
square roots when you multiply them
looks good
15 and minus six through two there are
some negative signs flying around there
do they all look like they're in the
right spots are we happy with the
negative science because that's a really
easy spot to knock up I'm happy good
so from there he's then simplified two
things the first two terms so that's
square root of eight we can write that
with a smaller number under the square
root which is a bit easier to work with
so instead of the square root of eight
what's he converted that into in the
next lane as 2 root 2 because the square
root of eight really is the square root
of 4 times the square root of two
they're they're out the front there's
your two okay so that looks good 2 times
what's that that's four so it looks good
and now we're finally in position where
everything is expanded out we just need
to what's it called again to get from
here to here collect like terms there's
the root twos there's four of them
there's the whole numbers
the rational numbers seven looks good
great job now let's have a look now that
I've put the numbers in the right spots
the formula of course that we were
talking about was that area is half a B
side C so you can pick any two sides but
the angle that you need which is the
mistake I made before the angle you need
has to be between those two sides and
that's a bit weird cuz usually you know
all these things and you have to find
this but what have I done kind of
switching around for ya I've given you
the area so this is what my working
would look like I'll go back to a more
legible color the area is on the
left-hand side so my first line of
working would start with a hundred
equals and then I start to put in the
information I know a half a and B it
doesn't matter which one is which sorry
so 15 X and then sine this angle in here
63 and degrees now I've been asked to
find X I need to make that the subject
it's here tangled up with all this other
stuff so what should I do to get it on
its own I should be dividing should know
this over here is 15 on to side 63 so if
I divide everything on this side I'm
gonna get 100 divided by 15 on to sign
63 yeah is that okay you see I've
divided everything over there leaving X
behind okay and that is just I mean you
can do a little bit of stuff with your
fractions there but because you need
your calculator anyway for this guy you
kind of well just go for it so what did
you get fourteen points two decimal
places is enough I didn't ask you for a
particular accuracy quick sense check
fourteen point nine six centimeters does
that sound about right
I think it looks okay so happy times you
often get questions if we want to make
it a little bit trickier instead of
giving you all the things on the right
hand side and ask you to find out the
subject we make you change the subject
and then rearrange but it's the same
formula underneath